december 17 1999 12 men make their way
through a port in hong kong in silence
praying they won't be caught at the
front of the group are the leaders known
in the business as snakeheads following
the snakeheads are poor chinese citizens
looking for a better life to support
their family back home the snake has
lead them to a 10 by 40 foot container
they push the would-be immigrants in
like cattle and lock the doors
in the darkness with only one phone a
box of basic food supplies and
containers to urinate and defecate in
the men settled down and prayed they
survive the two-week journey ahead their
destination a land of prosperity the
chinese call the gold mountain america
[Music]
where even the minimum wage is multiple
times higher than what they can earn
back home the price these would-be
immigrants paid to get smuggled into
america 40 000 each the problem is most
of them can't cough up that 40 grand so
they put their life savings into a small
deposit in exchange for a life of
indentured servitude in america slaving
away is basically a piece of property to
pay off the loan before they can ever
send any money back home to their
families
but over the last two decades the
business of alien smuggling in
particular has boomed
by bringing 10 or 20 or 30 chinese into
the united states at you know
approximately forty thousand dollars per
person that's a significant profit
margin
typically a family or village in china
or a sponsor in the united states will
scrape together enough for a down
payment to smuggle one of their sons
into the u.s
in the slave masters that smuggle them
into the country they're known as the
triads one of the most brutal organized
crime groups in the world and at forty
thousand dollars ahead a group of just
ten would-be immigrants brings them in
400 000 in cash and outstanding loans
smuggling a group of 10 every month is
4.8 million dollars a year off of just
120 customers if they're able to smuggle
10 people in every week that's already
19.2 million dollars a year but the
reality estimates back in 1997 put the
number as high as a hundred thousand
chinese immigrants smuggled into the us
every year that's four billion dollars
in just the us
and human smuggling is just one of their
lucrative rackets
chinese crime lords have operated as
shadow governments with their own laws
they're very secretive and
they're very best way to sum up
very violent trafficking human cargo is
just one of the many criminal rockets
that have made the chinese mob a global
force shocking money laundering white
collar fine computer crime
for years it was only wealthy criminals
billionaires in the super rich who could
afford to have financial advisors follow
them around helping them optimize every
money related decision if they wanted to
know where to invest their cash next
they'd have instant personalized expert
counsel on what was best for their
situation how to optimize for taxes what
legal entity to deal with and so on
because of that the ultra wealthy always
had a leg up on the rest of us they knew
where and when to invest and had all the
personal finance life hacks available to
them on demand this didn't sit well with
some people that understood this divide
so they created uprise today's video's
sponsor and uprise is free too so you're
going to want to stick around uprise is
basically the robin hood of financial
advisors but instead of democratizing
stock trading it democratizes personal
finance advice that's actually personal
here's how it works you sign up for
uprise and tell them a little bit about
yourself what your financial goals are
where you're at right now what you care
about and stuff like that then an actual
human being at uprise provides personal
finance advice to you that's actually
personal they optimize your finances
based on all the info you gave them they
help you decide where to invest when and
what loans or credit cards might be
worth it for you and they even help you
minimize your taxes before you file all
you have to do to get started is to sign
up for early access with the link in the
description and it really is free our
price only gets paid when clients sign
up for certain financial products they
recommend but that would never impact
the advice they give you like the rich
figured out long ago two brains are
always better than one and now you can
take advantage of this by signing up for
early access with the link below
[Music]
[Applause]
so you want to get rich as a triad well
you're gonna have to get initiated into
the family and learn the rules of the
game you see the triads consist of
hundreds of different gangs but for the
most part their rules and punishments
all follow the same guidelines first you
gotta work your way up the corporate
ladder much like the mafia you start off
as an associate an uninitiated member
called a blue lantern
after a while of doing grunt work if you
show some initiative you've shown that
you're not a rat then maybe you'll get
initiated into the family as a soldier
or an ordinary rank-and-file member
nicknamed 49ers to get initiated you'll
walk under a pair of swords to symbolize
you crossing the gates into this new
underworld they'll sacrifice an animal
then you'll drink its blood mixed with
your blood and wine and then you'll
recite the 36 oaths these else are along
the lines of after having entered the
hong gates i must treat the parents and
relatives of my sworn brothers as my own
kin i shall suffer the death of five
thunderbolts if i do not keep this oaf i
must never reveal hong secrets or signs
when speaking to outsiders if i do so i
would be killed by a myriad of swords
you know typical organized crime oaths
except for a lot of thunderbolts and
swords if you betray
[Music]
um
m
[Music]
then you're committed to a life of crime
servitude sacrifice or whatever the
leader of your triad chooses sure you
may get rich but in return you have to
promise complete loyalty even if you
have to die for it and speaking of your
leaders here's what the rest of the
corporate ladder looks like above the
initiated and uninitiated members you
have the white paper fan who is an
administrator the red pole who's the
enforcer the straw sander who's the
liaison officer the vanguard or the
operations officer the incense master
not incest you perverts incense master
the officer who's in charge of
initiating you into the family the
deputy mountain master the deputy or
second in command and at the very top
you have the mountain master also known
as the dragon head or the leader of the
family now keep in mind that these names
probably sound a lot cooler in chinese i
mean come on who wants to be called a
straw sandal but putting that aside now
that you're initiated let's make some
money baby
if there was an organized crime group
out there that can make money out of
almost anything it is the triads these
guys are willing to do anything for the
right price whether it's extorting fish
markets setting up illegal casinos or
even entering the entertainment industry
if there is money to be made they'll be
right there finding ways to exploit it
like the 12 men we talked about at the
start of this video one of the tribe's
main revenue streams is human smuggling
it's estimated they smell good more than
a hundred thousand people into the us
every year and at least 35 000 into the
uk one woman called sister ping in
chinese immigrant communities who's also
known as the mother of all snakes to the
critics out there was a ruthless
businesswoman and she made a 40 million
dollar fortune smuggling hundreds of
thousands of immigrants into the us and
eu these immigrants have to pay between
20 and 40 000 just to get on the
container ship where they might die to
make their way to countries in hopes of
better jobs better lives and more
freedom to support their families back
home but like we saw earlier that's
rarely the case instead they spend most
of their lives working off their debts
and even once they paid all the money
back they find that getting out isn't
that easy then there's the operation
that the triads are most famous for
substance smuggling and today they're
one of the biggest smugglers of china
whites also known as heroin opium plants
are grown in the golden triangle a
triangle that stretches between thailand
laos and miramar they're harvested and
refined into heroin in china and then
smuggled into europe and the us by
triads it's estimated that trafficking
heroin alone is worth more than 200
billion dollars a year
you'd imagine making more than 200
billion dollars a year is enough for any
criminal organization but because the
triads are broken up into so many
autonomous groups and they don't have
one single leader or godfather over all
of them this money is spread out over a
lot of people a lot of groups in a lot
of different countries so if you're a
smaller triad and you don't have the
connections to run huge substance or
people smuggling networks you turn to
the classics extortion but with an asian
twist in asia the triads have found
hundreds of ways to extort people and
businesses these businesses include the
usual suspects like restaurants clubs
construction companies and casinos but
some of the tribes have gotten really
creative and have even gone after fish
wholesalers street hackers mini bus
drivers and movie stars they even coerce
some of asia's biggest celebrities into
starring in low quality movies or
working for less pay in exchange for
getting reimbursed for their services by
the movie directors or funders and if
you don't pay up you and your business
will suffer the consequences
and if extortion and smuggling aren't
your taste as the leader of a triad
there's also illegal gambling
asians love gambling
setting up a casino in the basement of a
restaurant or club is a great way to
make quick money especially in places
like taiwan where gambling is illegal
outside of a casino even though there
aren't any casinos to begin with and
then there's also murder for hire
kidnapping loan sharking white collar
crime online crime counterfeiting it
really is like a supermarket for crime
but how did one of asia's most feared
organized crime crews become so
ubiquitous
[Music]
according to the triads their story
began in 1671 at a shaolin monastery yes
the same shaolin that started kung fu
the emperor of china during the king
dynasty needed to stop an invasion and
turn to the monks for help the shaolin
were powerful warriors and beat the
enemy without losing a single man
impressed by the strength and skill the
emperor's advisor suggested that if they
were strong enough to win against the
barbarians they would be strong enough
to overthrow the emperor so he would
have to do something about it rather
quickly so he sent his men to the
monastery they got the monks drunk while
celebrating their victory and then they
set fire to the temple killing all of
them but five these five surviving mugs
fled and made it their life's mission to
overthrow the king emperor and restore
the ming dynasty's rule for this purpose
a new secret brotherhood was formed the
triads this is the story most triad
members will tell you and is also the
story passed around most cities and
towns in asia building up so much
mystery and romanticism around the group
which they used to their advantage as
often as possible but the problem is
that story is probably just that a story
a story of pure legend and patriotism
the truth is there are dozens of stories
out there about how the triads came into
existence but most researchers agree
they originated with something called
the heaven and earth society but how
that happened is different every time
you ask the most likely explanation is
that they started in the fujian province
in the 1700s china was in a state of
economic upheaval and young men had to
travel far and wide to find work and
make a living but four gym was china's
wild west and the roads they traveled
were often filled with bandits and
robbers so these men would travel in
groups to stay safe they would swear to
protect each other and over time became
more like a brotherhood compared to a
convenient travel arrangement eventually
these brotherhoods turned into secret
societies that used crime to make a
living in the west the idea of secret
societies sound weird and conspiratorial
but in the 1700s secret societies were
all the rage in china and in 1761 a
group of monks founded the heaven and
earth society to symbolize the meaning
of their name heaven above earth below
and man in the middle they took the
emblem of a triangle and this would be
the origins of the name triads the triad
still believing in the legendary story
of their purpose to overthrow the
emperor and restore the ming dynasty
fought against king's supporters and
drew support from other brotherhoods who
wanted a greater purpose and a reason
for stealing and brutality the emperor
feared the mythology and legends
associated with the heaven and earth
society and started chasing down anyone
associated with them so the groups had
to go underground to escape punishment
and it was around this time that the
triads became intrinsically linked to
chinese secret societies and they used
this notoriety and feared to become one
of the biggest organized crime groups in
the world but the evolution of the
tribes was far from over
[Music]
prohibition in america was the catalyst
for the italian american mafia and all
this talk of bull leggings what is bull
leggings mood licking alcohol made the
mafia millions and set them up to
dominate america the triads went through
a similar catalyst except instead of
alcohol it was the ban of opium in 1799
opium comes from a poppy plant and is
commonly smoked and used to make heroin
the triads took over this new black
market became the masters at smuggling
it and ran opium dense throughout asia
which are kind of like hookah lounges
today
then came the 1900s world war ii
political turmoil civil war the rise of
the communist party famine and overall
suffering led to the giant chinese
diaspora where the chinese population
started immigrating everywhere they
could in search of a better life they
went to hong kong southeast asia san
francisco new york london and the
service provider that helped them
immigrate
none other than the triads
they first mastered the opium trade and
now it was time to master the art of
human smuggling both of which they still
do today
mao zedong takes power in 1949
under the new rule of the chinese
communist party and just a few months
later they announced their first
political campaign the campaign to
suppress counter-revolutionaries
anyone who represented a threat to the
party's power was labeled a
counter-revolutionary
counter-revolutionaries were arrested
convicted in mass trials then they were
either sentenced to labor reform or
executed
estimates say that 2.6 million people
were arrested and one of the
counter-revolutionary groups that were
targeted secret societies and that
included the triads the triads were
effectively stamped out of mainland
china and like their fellow chinese
citizens the triads had to seek refuge
elsewhere mainly in places like hong
kong which was still under british rule
south east asia san francisco new york
and london that's why places like hong
kong are a hotbed for triads today and
why triads have an iron grip on
chinatowns all over the world unlike
other organized crime groups like the
yakuza and the mafia who went
international because they were drowning
in cash and needed to invest it
elsewhere the family is making an
investment in havana this is a little
gift for the president oh that's great
the triads went international because
they had no other choice
they were put into exile
one of the groups that fled to hong kong
is called the sun yi on they're the
biggest triads in the world
headquartered in hong kong and china
with over 25 000 members active in the
uk us and europe today even though
they're the biggest triad in existence
they're the perfect example of the
secrecy surrounding these criminal
organizations no one knows who the
dragon head is and those 25 000 members
most people mention well that's just a
guess the reality is that they could be
much bigger than anyone imagines
then there's the 14k probably the most
violent triad around today and the
biggest trial group today second only to
the sun yeon they're based in hong kong
but also spread out internationally
they're mostly responsible for substance
smuggling but also make their money from
robberies assassinations weapons
trafficking and gambling all over the
world remember sister ping the woman who
made 40 million smuggling people her
boyfriend was a 14k member one of the
reasons the 14k is so violent is because
there's no dragon head that can control
them all there's just too many different
subgroups spread over too many different
countries so the factions fight between
themselves each one of them trying and
failing to become the leaders of the
group
what's surprising is just how little we
know about the triads compared to other
organized crime groups like the mafia
yakuza or even the russian mafia even
though the triads are one of the biggest
organized crime groups in the world
[Music]
because of the structure of the triads
with so many small self-contained groups
all over the world
they're far more difficult for law
enforcement to take down compared to the
italian mafia which was headed by just 5
families sure they can lock up a few
dragon heads but there are just too many
groups and even more dragon has that
seemed to appear out of nowhere i like
to describe chinese organized crime as
the flu virus because they're constantly
mutating into different groups and
different alliances and
and therefore they're very difficult to
investigate
and it doesn't help that they're one of
the most adaptable crime rings out there
today the triads even act as the chinese
communist party's muscle chinese
officials even allegedly got a triad
gang to attack pro-democracy protesters
in hong kong recently
one of their biggest rackets money
laundering for the rich famous and ultra
powerful dude macau the las vegas of the
east which has more than 200 billion
dollars flowing through it every year
but that's the story for another video
in fact the triads are so widespread
that western police predict that they
will even surpass where the italian
mafia was at their height within the
next century
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
you